ça a été un carton la mi-saison une
surman canal un carton absolu donc
qu'est ce qui se passe quand c'est un
carton qu'elle est en deux tailles canal
se dit ah on a trouvé la poule aux oeufs
d'or
on veut une saison 2 ayant même c'est en
quoi
la présence de la miss mission noël
et la saison 3 je crois que ces mariages
et ça c'est ça n'allait pas bien ben oui
tant mieux cela mais
c'est pas ton émission aujourd'hui
alors donc la nouvelle saison sera
diffusée le vendredi 17 décembre c'est à
dire vendredi là à 19h en exclusivité
sur canal la première saison a cartonné
la deuxième saison je vous le dis c'est
encore le niveau dessus même au niveau
de la production ou c'est un truc de fou
franchement c'est génial bravo à vous de
le coupler partialité travaux équipe 1
loïc tout ça thurman 4 usa qui ont
cartes qui ont cartonné rachid vous
offriront aussi incroyable on croit voir
trop trop vraiment n'est trop longtemps
s'attendait pas à autant faire autant
dans la première oui je sais mais c'est
et on essaie que tout le monde vous veut
maintenant tout le monde veut qu à kevin
tout le monde veut la mif et vous restez
bien sûr mais canal away bouge pas non
plus demander une augmentation alors
dans ces cas là
[Applaudissements]
j'ai rien à voir là dedans mais je chie
pas ou désabonnez les augmentations si
jamais vous regardez on a une vidéo
juste eric tu es magnifique regarde
[Musique]
comme m
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
carla qui est dit que j'aime et je
prenais deux et je vous dis j'en parlais
tout à l'heure avec le président de sce
vite francs capitaux qui a longuement
discuté avec vous avez vu il me disait
j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour eux parce
que vous êtes désamour voilà je voulais
le dire et c'est toutes mes équipes me
disent que ça a été un bonheur de
travailler avec vous voilà donc merci la
saison 2 arrive et carrelage et une
petit truc c'est un petit truc pour toi
j'aimerais que tu viennes un petit peu
faire de du tpm paix avec nous à la
rentrée au moins une fois par semaine je
sais que dans la loi on en avait parlé
je trouve que vraiment été génial en
plus tu es toujours souriante tu aimes
la vie est toi tu es avec moi au moins
et
j'ai besoin de personne avec moi dans
cette émission quelques nanas peluche à
la voilà
tu peux alors j'aime pas quand tu
regardes isabelle quand tu vises un tu
as fait un petit peu de peine se sait
ces quelques cas voilà qui est encore la
regarder en garder qu'un gars comme elle
bouge bien encore
c'est carla je la reconnais
là ça va oui si tu aimes bien oui elle
nettement moins
pas du tout elle pas d'or regardez c'est
bien qu'un ses coutumes et une arrière
grand mère
j'ai connu maria arrière grand mère les
bains la voilà elle est là ce soir les
lyonnais de retour c'est dingue hein